[Musique]
ce qui va changer évidemment pour les
saint quentinois ce sont les rythmes de
collecte et les fréquences de collecte
je prends l'exemple par exemple des
ordures ménagères un effectivement
aujourd'hui en visionnaire on passait
deux fois par semaine à l'avenir en 2021
on ne passera plus qu'une fois par
semaine on dans le cadre de la loi de
transition énergétique de 2015
et cette loi impose aux collectivités de
réduire de 50 % le volume de déchets
admis en site de stockage d'ici 2025
on est en 2020 bientôt 2021 et notre
nouveau marché démarre en 2021 2025 si
demain un de 50 % de réduction
c'est une contrainte forte on a fait le
choix à saint-quentin-en-yvelines de
transformer cette contrainte en enjeu un
enjeu environnemental
depuis qu'on a commencé à communiquer
sur les nouveaux marchés
il ya beaucoup de mains qui se lèvent et
de gens qui nous disent mais vous vous
rendez pas compte c'est aberrant on n'y
arrivera jamais ce n'est pas possible
alors voilà effectivement la première
démarche de saint quentin a été celle de
dire il faut qu on impulse
cette dynamique de changement de deux
fondements de nos pensées pour arriver à
produire moins
si on collecte différemment on va
forcément obligé les saint quentinois a
résonné peut-être différemment